好的 各位早安
礼拜五是美股的四乎日
那我们今天就来复盘一下四乎日要怎么操作
那四乎日指的就是
美股的指数的期货选择权和
各股的期货选择权这四项商品同时结算的日子
那因为是结算日嘛
所以多空就会势必有一波非常激烈的交战
那波动就会比较大
那有一些
老师或是有些书会说四乎日就尽量不要操作
但是
对于我们短线的当中教育者来说
四乎日有波动那当然就
更是应该要参与行情的好时机
那我们就来看一下
这个
带来不祥的四乎日
是要怎么操作
那我们都一样
就是我建议如果看夜盘的话
到九点半之前是不用看的
因为通常都没什么波动
就从美股开完之后开始看
因为欧股对于世界的经济的影响
算是很小
那全地球还是要跟着美股走啦
所以欧股时间可以不用看
好那我们就从九点半开始看
然后
这个前两分钟就出现了一个
现行的特殊情况
就是
这个
这两根
绿K都没有达到报答量的标准
但是都有超过三百口
然后在下一根被红K涨过
那
第二根的这个
连续
这个
接近报答量的
第二根黑K
如果被涨过的话
有可能到
就是
到这边的话
第二根也被涨过
那这两根加起来
其实也是
属于报答量嘛
所以
他们
还是会需要反向停损
那所以在
我定的这个特殊规则里面其中有一条就是
这样的现行是
要在
第二根的这个绿K被涨过的时候多难进场
那我会特别讲当然就是因为这个
我这是一套非常固定的完整的
这个策略嘛
那
所以这个
就是
虽然
在
两分钟之后就被停损了
就是
这根被涨过是
4-5
4倍涨过嘛
所以是
多
4-5-5
然后
停损
损在
4-4-7
所以是一个
8点的停损
6+2
那虽然他马上就停损了
但
就是
因为我的规则是
非常明确的
就是
大家来打
应该会都是在完全一样的点位
所以我也不会
就是
因为这单停损
然后他又是特殊线
那我就
不把他列入讨论
因为
就是
有学过策略的人一定会知道
就是要在这个地方进
这个地方出
好那所以
就是
我讲的
这几次这些复盘都是
非常明确而且符合规则
而且大家都会在一样的点位进出
如果你有
照着那个
策略操作
没有自己加一些奇怪的想法
好那所以这个
第一单是
停损
就是
一个
呃
好
这种线行李的好处是会短停损啦
然后停力的话可以拉长到2R以上
因为第2根也被
涨过之后就有可能是一段抗钱
那这个
这个
奉献暴手笔就是在两倍
好
第一单好像有点讲太久了
就是
跟你们讲一下
这个
特殊线行我还是会拿出来讲
就算是停损
因为
这个就是符合策略的进场
那第1单是
停损了8点
然后
OK然后这边出现了一个报答量嘛
所以是
这个
这个是
呃
如果被涨过
所以你这边挂一个
476的
出价多单
然后
然后这边
这边就是一直等嘛
哎呦
这边
超过了
这边有一个476
达到476
所以这边
加476进场
然后呢
就是
挂
停损在
那
75-60
是15嘛
再加2
上下一个Tick
所以是17
17乘2
是
所以是
476+34
是510
那所以
这个标准挂
2倍
2R的话
就是
2倍Risk
就是510
停力
那
不过有另外一个特殊规则就是
呃因为500
就是100倍数是对于所有的教育者来说的一个心理关卡
那约是100倍数嘛
在我很前面的影片我讲过很多次我就不重讲了
那所以
这个510的停力
这个按照我的调整的话应该是要调整在520停力
就是
不要在
500这个撑压过去一点点的地方停力
你要嘛就是调整498
不然就是调整520
好
那
不过没关系我们就是
记录2R的点数
这边
停力
34点
虽然应该
可以停力到44
好
那这边停力也一单34点
然后这边
这个
有点可惜啊
这个不是继续红K
不然的话
跌破就
就可以空单进场了
那不过
就是我们就照
策略走
他既然是绿K
那就不符合进场条件
所以就
不打
好
然后
幸运的躲开了
因为他是绿K
所以
变成是掌过打多单
那
就是
就是如果是主观线型的话
应该很多人会在这边打空单
不过
刚好
这个
运气不错
按照基本策略执行的话
这个就是一个
呃
这个不是绿K
这根才是绿K
加
5的多单
那停损就是在这根
的第一点
所以是
那所以Risk
是
21+2
那所以会挂在
46点外停例
好
然后
然后这两根都是报大量嘛
所以
呃
挂在46点外停例
但是
这边掌过的时候
你要记得
你的停损不要挂在
就是你停例还是挂在46点外
但是停损就要
改
挂在
这根红K的第一点
然后挂两倍
例如说
打10口
的
算了
我们就讲一口
大部分人应该打一口
打一口的多单
你就挂
两口的空单
这个
往回打
好反正就是两倍嘛
你若是打10
这个
三口的话
就是挂6口的空单
出价
好然后这边
就是
这根在出现的时候
就是把
下面这个NIT取消
然后
挂在这边
NIT就是出价进场
然后这根就是
跌破了嘛
所以就出价进场
那是进场两倍
所以是把
刚刚
535的多单
两倍
空单
在
所以是
一个18点的
获利
然后
好反正就是
我就是都有记录
好这边是一个18点的获利
然后
把它拉进来
是不是你们就被爆雷了
好然后
这根的
Risk
是8加2嘛
所以是10
所以是553
扣20
所以是533
然后这边就达到533了
所以这边又再停利20点
然后
然后这边都没有爆大量
所以就是
再看有没有讯号
OK
然后这边又出现了讯号
这个出来就挂513
然后在这边就把513取消
挂521空单
然后这边就521空单进场到嘛
然后Risk
是11加2
所以是
13乘2
所以是在
521-26
所以是495
然后495这边是有到的
但是这个也是一样嘛
100的倍数是心理关卡嘛
所以你可以改成挂502
或者是挂480的停利
但是因为
这个可能会
就是
就是尽量啦
我基本上我都是
往远的挂
因为是顺势交易嘛
你往进的挂就是
提早停利嘛
但是
在我的教育逻辑里面
提早停利是不好的
所以基本上
如果是
2R是在
100倍数
之后的话
我会就再
多往后面挂一些
那大概是挂在
就是
就是看你要往后挂多少
通常我是挂在20点之外
就是
会算是比较容易到的地方
然后还算是在
这个刚突破的时候的
的位置
好
然后所以如果有挂480
是会停利到
那不过没关系我们就
这个点数计算我们就还是用
用2R的
来计算
然后
然后后面就都
都没有再有
400口的报答量
就是
就是这样
那
就是
就是这样
所以
这个总体加起来的话
按照2R基本策略
会是赚85点
那如果
两次都有
这个因为
考虑100倍数调整的话
就会是
85加
就会赚到
那
我觉得我
我跟
大家
基本策略的操作
有一
有一点点
就是
有时候我会再继续延后停离
就是如果
如果成本拉开的话
我通常会
倾向于稍微往后停离
但是但是都还是符合标准的
就是
例如说我考虑100倍数
或者是
我考虑了
日盘的
这个近期最高最低点
之类的
这个我也会稍微纳入参考
好
那不过就是
但我觉得
一开始大家就练习
用基本策略2R进出
这个
然后
熟悉了之后你再
试着
考虑一些
其他的
细微的调整
细微调整
也是
就是
就是稍微
好
大概就是这样啦
这就是
这个
二零二二年
九月十六美股
四五日的
夜盘复盘
然后
当然交易日
或是在礼拜一
好
希望这集
影片大家也有学到一些东西
就这样啦
大家拜拜